yes I you know I think studying the
intelligence or the behavior the
evolution of another species is a
wonderful way to gain perspective on who
we are because it's very difficult you
know to really think about who you
manzara you Minh intelligence in a
vacuum because we didn't evolve in a
vacuum so yes dolphins Dolph study of
dolphin brains and intelligence gives us
a tremendous amount of of perspective on
human intelligence I mean when you look
at we're so used to thinking of our own
species as on top of everything on top
of nature superior to the other species
more intelligent qualitatively different
and when you look at our brain we see
that we have these large brains in the
size for the size of our bodies and yet
if you look at dolphins you see that
they too have extraordinarily big brains
for their bodies they are very very
intelligent and even though their brains
evolved along a different trajectory
than our own so they're structured a
little bit differently the thing that we
have in common is the fact that we both
evolved very large complex brains so
that tells us that there's more than one
way to be highly intelligent sentient
and complex on this planet not just the
human way but the dolphin way as well
you